no I was always afraid of I'm afraid of
bullies so they were bullies and your
friend yeah I mean I was a bully but I
remember my brother remember that way
his dad's guy Derek who was a who look
like a son the opener yeah why you used
to pick on I used it he had ice cream in
his hand I just pushed in his face right
but then he challenged me cuz that's it
don't do that
we're fighting I go oh yeah feel [ __ ]
right we meet on a dirt road he kicked
the living [ __ ] out of him and then the
next day I was like a nerd too
I was like hanging out with them playing
flutes no I went it took flew class I
had a gopher dish no I did a dick full
class I'll be a flutist ok but I thought
I was like you know yeah I'm not like
that yeah but um no bullies are
important man you need it yeah there's
bullies in comedy now yeah I mean I mean
I mean I don't want to say I mean he's
super nice but Rogan Joe Rogan he's not
a bully but you know like the other day
I was like standing outside the Comedy
Store and he didn't make contact but he
started running down sunset you know I
mean he goes Lee or something he said
says my name and he goes ah and he does
a kick but he's he misses my leg by like
an inch that's how that's how good he is
how much control we had so much power
behind it right and I made a noise I
went like that and then the doorman
laughed at me and he kind of laughed he
walked away it was like that's kind of
you know when Bill Byrne like you know
me he talks to me about you gotta have a
kid yeah it'll change your life
the other night he was doing that and me
just listening like I don't ever throw
my opinions and then when I did you know
what he said I got to go home no because
I go be in Kelowna were thinking meteor
I got to go home I keep writing got in
the car you drove away I'm like I can't
even see my opinion
no burger bullies in you know you know
I'll tell you in at the cop in the
comedy scene yeah here's the guy that
here's the guys that play both sides the
guys that are like you're the cool kids
that hang out with the hashers you know
who one of them is I realized Tom Segura
yet because I was bullying Craig so
Craig one of my openers he was like he
would he I'm not gonna say what he did
but he crossed the line with me and so I
cornered him yeah because because I
yelled at him so I I cornered him like
if you ever [ __ ] do that again I
swear [ __ ] god I'll bury you and then
Tom came up and goes hey guys I just
shook my hand he's chicken at and then
you should everyone's hand and
everyone's like hey Tommy you know I
mean he's the good keys that popular kid
in high school yeah yeah cuz that bully
yeah yeah Shaffir bully bully
who else is a bully D'Elia is popular
kid then there's jocks Brent Ernst was a
high jock there are jobs Sebastian
Maniscalco Jacques you know and then
there are like sorority girls
iliza shlesinger sorority girl hey or
like the popular girl who doesn't even
say hi to you anymore yeah like I can't
even say hi to her you are the no nerds
Ali Wong Ali Wong is the nerd that
everyone knows is gonna be president in
the United States so that she becomes
pres class president that's Ali Wong and
then there are ones that are like just
you know the good nobodies and there's a
lot of them you know the nobodies but
there's like a a slew of nobodies yeah
they just hang around right and they
just know they're never gonna do
anything you know there's you say hi to
them too they're human beings yeah but
you know what dude it's like you know
you should I I know my position in the
world my push visit and in because
there's laws in this country that
protect me from physically getting harm
and if I get harmed I can sue or call
the cops or whatever so you know I'm
willing to play a victim every once in a
while it's missing in the comedy scene
yeah but um I'm still a popular kid
right yeah I'm still a part of the
popular cool group you know Jim Carrey
knows me Jim Carrey knows Bobby Bob
Saget knows me Bob Saget
you know those well Bob Saget says
condescending things I think you gonna
get naked again he always says that
every time I see him and I want to go
you know a Bob I don't do that I do but
tell him I don't you do also the cool
kid Spade David Spade he does snide
comments you mean yeah we just come from
the you know a circus what kind of
sandals are those mm-hmm
it'll just walk away and everyone will
allow cuz it's David Spade cool and then
I'll laugh even though it hurts me right
but it's like yeah I'll get angry a
little bit oh I get affected by oh yeah
yeah yeah like job babe Ruben said these
pants yeah I do do that like Jeff Ross
system to do that he's like you're on a
show right yeah I go yeah they have a
wardrobe department dang I go yeah can
you just ask for clothes and I'm like
wow
last week he bought a really
cool-looking bright-colored Montclair
attack vest yeah and he wore to the
comedy store he was really excited to
show his friends his new thing and he
came home and he was really bummed
yeah music beep they said I shouldn't
wear this on stage again yeah and then
yeah and then now he hates his $800
Moncler this no you can have it I'm
gonna try to work it you know what else
I'm doing with that jacket what I've
been googling the jacket and other
people wearing it well you see what I
need to be wearing with it I like the
whole like the models yeah yeah and I go
oh I gotta do that but all the models
are good-looking but when they haul or
do they wear for pants a camo pants well
this is where like clothes I don't even
[ __ ] have yeah like other Moncler
pants you know so it's like yeah a
people made fun of me all night oh yeah
yeah hey what are you a jelly belly
you know I mean people saying with my
jacket on yellow are you wearing a vest
cuz I cuz I'm yellow Skinner he's like I
stuck with you it one night though the
first time I [ __ ] remember cuz you
wore yes yeah I haven't worn it since I
can remember you was checking out
something Mary you like guys yeah yeah I
regret it getting it don't you forget
the more expensive one too
yeah it should I got the more expensive
one but uh yeah so you know mean I still
get bullied but you know what we should
do we should do we should speak up for
ourselves out everyone listening now um
slept King said speak up for yourself
don't die read the situation but you
know you should always just I you know I
just have this inner thing of like I
have to just take it but I don't the
prime example is the movie with
hereditary when we did that you know but
that was a weird podcast huh
[Music]